après avoir travaillé dix ans pour de
grandes enseignes cosmétiques stéphanie
gastal d'un a décidé de créer sa propre
marque
un projet né fin 2019 à saint germain en
laye d'où m'est venu effectivement l'ina
et c'est avant tout le lin donc je suis
originaire de normandie fille et
petite-fille de l'ine kurt liniculteurs
normand donc le lyme est apparu comme
une évidence pour devenir le parfait
messager d'une cause de culture d'une
cosmétique à la fois locale et
coresponsable plus riches de bien fait
malgré les restrictions sociales
l'entreprise souhaite être proche des
femmes un produit n'est validé que
lorsqu'il est 100% approuvé par les
futures clientes pour l'heure fait
tester également les soins sous forme
d'un questionnaire donc halte est à
domicile
les soumissions et elle suivait ce
question par question le questionnaire
et elles répondent en fonction de
différents critères la sensorialité
l'efficacité des produits approuvés par
les professionnels avec l'attribution de
récompenses officielles comme le prix du
meilleur produit naturel des cosmétiques
mag ward pour le soin de jour savoir
concrètement surtout à une époque on a
besoin de savoir quelle quelle est
l'origine de nos produits
j'ai été très rassurée par la provenance
et par la qualité des produits j'ai pu
faire les tests et puis un an et demi
que je les utilise et jambes ou j'en
perçois quotidiennement les bienfaits
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la cosmétique
peut parfois faire peur il faut le dire
avec l'ina et je rassure les femmes de
par la composition en entre 98 et 100 %
d'ingrédients d'origine naturelle
jusqu'à 59 % d'ingrédients issus de
l'agriculture biologique
la marque est implantée dans une dizaine
de boutiques privilégiant le made in
france et la cosmétique naturelle et sur
des plates formes internet
en plus d'avoir son propre site